AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT
GAME, PREZ DISPENSERS.
PREZ DISPENSERS.
XENOPHOBIC SWEET POTATO AND
WISPY HUMAN QUEEF, DONALD TRUMP,
IS...
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
NOT THE...
>> HE'S QUEEFING NOW.
>> HARDWICK: HE'S QUEEFING RIGHT
NOW!
>> YEAH. YEAH, OUT OF HIS MOUTH.
HE'S QUEEFING OUT OF HIS MOUTH.
(ALL GROWLING AND SPUTTERING)
>> HARDWICK: "IT'S NOT MY FAULT.
I TOLD YOU THIS WOULD HAPPEN IF
WE DID DOGGY."
(GROWLING)
'CAUSE YOU KNOW HOW DOGS QUEEF
ALL THE TIME.
HE'S NOT THE ONLY CELEBRITY
WHO'S HAD A HARD TIME FORMING
COMPLETE SENTENCES TO RUN FOR
OFFICE.
RONALD REAGAN WAS FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THIS COUNTRY, IN
CASE YOU DON'T REMEMBER.
UH, HE WAS A MOVIE STAR BEFORE
HE BECAME PRESIDENT.
AND BOTH ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER
AND JESSE VENTURA GOT ELECTED ON
THE "IF IT BLEEDS, WE CAN KILL
IT" PLATFORM.
NOW, IF THIS TREND CONTINUES,
THE EMBARRASSING CELEBRITIES OF
TODAY WILL BE EMBARRASSING
POLITICIANS OF TOMORROW.
SO, COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA SHOW
YOU A CELEBRITY.
FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT YOU TO
TELL ME WHAT THEIR FIRST ACTION
AS PRESIDENT WILL BE.
FIRST UP, KANYE WEST.
(BELL DINGS)
JERMAINE.
>> UH, RENAME THE WEST WING THE
KANYE WEST WING...
>> NICE.
>> ...AND ANY ROOM KIM IS IN THE
OVAL OFFICE.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
>> 'CAUSE OF HER ASS!
>> HARDWICK: YEP.
>> OH!
I GOT IT, I GOT IT, I GOT IT.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS. NEXT UP,
UH, ADAM CONOVER, RONDA-RONDA
ROUSEY.
>> UH, EAT APPLESAUCE FOR THE
NEXT 11 MONTHS.
>> HARDWICK: OH, (BEEP). OH,
DAMN.
I DIDN'T... HE SAID IT, RONDA
ROUSEY!
HE SAID IT!
>> AND THEN SHE'LL BE BACK IN
THERE!
SHE'LL BE BACK IN IT!
>> HARDWICK: WHAT, JERMAINE?
>> UH, IMMEDIATELY LOSE HER
PRESIDENCY TO SOMEBODY NO ONE'S
EVER HEARD OF.
>> HARDWICK: OH, (BEEP)! OH,
DAMN.
I GOT TO GIVE YOU POINTS FOR
THAT.
>> SHE GOT KNOCKED THE (BEEP)
OUT!
>> HARDWICK: I GOT TO GIVE YOU
POINTS FOR THAT.
NEXT UP, JOHNNY DEPP.
JOHNNY DEPP.
ALICE.
>> MAKE TIM BURTON CHANCELLOR OF
GOTH BULL (BEEP).
>> HARDWICK: YEAH. ALL RIGHT.
POINTS.
FINALLY, BEYONCE.
PRESIDENT BEYONCE. JERMAINE.
>> START A CAN DRIVE FOR THE
SURVIVING MEMBERS OF DESTINY'S
CHILD.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT.
OH, (BEEP). OH, DAMN.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE'S GONNA TOP
THAT ONE.